hey what's up my name is samuel leeds
i'm a property investor and one of the
things that i
have done very successfully and it's
been in the newspapers people have
talked about it i've been asked to speak
at events
is i've bought a massive property
portfolio i've built a
humongous property portfolio right now
i'm actually outside a castle you can't
really see very well in this video i'm
gonna do another video about it tomorrow
and my whole portfolio i built up with
no money
and in this video i just want to give
you a little bit of a low down about
how it's possible to buy a property or
to build a whole portfolio
starting with no money now if you hear
some noises in the background my little
boy
is in the video he's learning see i
reckon he'll be a millionaire about
2025.
i was a millionaire by the age i was 25
he's gonna have extra help so
how do you buy a house without using any
of your own money so the first way is
you can do something called a lease
option agreement which is where you buy
a house
but you don't pay for it right away you
pay for it later now to do this with
most things is is not good
because if you buy a house say you buy a
house
and uh and you live in it and the house
is not an
asset it's a liability you don't want to
buy and pay for it later
because it's not giving you any money
whereas if you buy a house that's going
to give you rent
and you agree to pay for it later then
you can save that rent
and then later when you buy it you use
the rent that you've saved
to put down as the down payment that's
called a lease option agreement
different from a delayed sale because a
lease option agreement
you have the option not the obligation
to buy it so that's how i got started
with a lot of my early early
properties another way if you've not got
any money
is to find properties that are really
good investments
negotiate them below market value and
rather than buying them yourself
you can ask people to joint venture with
you now this is something called
joint venture which is like and people
say how do you do that
listen when i when i was starting out in
property i didn't have any money so i
used to find really good projects
really good properties i'd say listen
i've got the prophecy
i've negotiated it i've got the team
i've got the knowledge the expertise the
time the inclination
you mr investor have got the money how
about this how about you put the money
in
i'll do everything else and then we'll
go 50 50 on the profits
that's the least option sorry that's not
these options that's joint ventures
and if you think that that's too good to
be true and no one would do that
i am often the person with the money now
so now i'm 29 last year i put over a
million pounds of my own money
into other people's deals where they
found the deals
i said i'll fund them they didn't put in
any money but they have a percentage of
the profits
so that's joint venture another thing
you can do warren buffett talks about
controlling things
and that's you can control properties
you can take over a property that you
don't own
you can pay a guaranteed rent to the
owner but then you can convert it into
something like
a hmo house of multiple occupancy you
can convert it
you can convert it it's a bit noisy
around here
it's a bit naughty but the roosters see
where i am right now
you know you can actually i'm really
close to the safari park you can
actually hear
the lions roar the lions raw
um so you can control it and then just
get a
and then you'll benefit from cash flow
and then hey if it's going well
ask for an option to buy at the end
that's how you turn a rent to rent into
a lease option agreement
another way you can do it see i could
just i could just rattle off
i could just rattle off loads of ways
another way to buy a property without
using any of your own money
is package deals and pass them on to
investors
and charge charge and investor fee and
then with that money that you're making
you've never owned the property
do that a few times and then use that
money to put down on your own property
so honestly here here are the successful
people in business
because you know most people on the
sunday time is richlist what do they
invest in they invest in property
and uh most millionaires that i know and
multi-millionaires
are self-made so you want to be a
self-made millionaire
don't worry about where you are right
now don't worry about your family
worry about don't worry about how much
money you've got right now
you've got to think about how to be
creative you know yeah i creatively
financed this this this building
um now renovating it i'm also creatively
financing the renovation
um bought this house say house this is
actually a castle
it's got its own wikipedia page eight
acres of land
bought this for eight hundred thousand
pounds a couple years ago
gross development value is going to be
6.35 million
and then i'm going to refinance it and
pull my money back out
uh if you want to know about this
building i'm planning on doing a video
about this
i'll give i'll give you a tour talk
about this building tomorrow
so if you've got questions about this
about this castle
let me know i'll give you the lowdown
i'll comment
comment your questions i'll do a whole
video solely about this building
tomorrow and uh listen get creative
get courageous if you're courageous and
creative
you're gonna succeed in this business
i'm watching where i step because
i've not actually got any shoes on i'm
scared i'm gonna stand on something
sharp
but hey folks uh i started with nothing
and if i can do it you can too smash the
like button you want to see more videos
smash the like button you've got
questions for me
put them in the comment box i read all
the comments i'll be responding do more
videos
and um i hope you found this video
helpful hope you found this video
helpful
joint venture lease option agreement
rent to rent
deal packaging buy refurbish refinance
rent these are all strategies
that you should really learn if you want
to be successful in property
most people save up money and then use
that money to buy their own house
and then pay off their mortgage and it
takes them 50 years and then by the time
they pay their mortgage off
they retire i don't believe in that
that's what the system wants you to do
i believe in using other people's money
joint venturing raising finance that's
what i've not even talked about
raise finance get the money from the
bank and then invest it
you might pay the bank five percent ten
percent but if you can turn that into
twenty thirty percent
there's certainly an infinite return on
investment so there's so many ways
most important asset is not property the
most important important asset
is your brand because the bigger you
grow the bigger your knowledge grows
the bigger your bank grows so i would
suggest investing time
money energy resources in yourself first
then in property make money as a
property entrepreneur
invest money as a property investor get
wealth get financially independent
subscribe to this youtube channel and
anyway i'll give you a whole tour of
this tomorrow
give you an update hope you're excited
about that i'll see you real soon